the streets response to Iraq's prime
minister-designate came fast and it was
loud and clear Muhammad Allah is
rejected protesters in Baghdad Sahara
chanted on Saturday night after two
months of political deadlock president
Barham salad chose Mohammed Oh feck
allow it to replace Adel Abdel Mahdi who
resigned two months ago amid widespread
anti-government protests days prior to
allow his appointment we spoke to
protesters in Tahrir who saw him as
another incarnation of a political
system that has failed them for sure
he's rejected any person who has a
relation with the parties from close or
far he's a reject from all the people in
general because for 16 years we haven't
seen anything from them just destruction
indeed Alawi is part and parcel of
Iraq's post 2003 political establishment
a cousin of former vice president and
prime minister I at allowi
he served as a member of parliament and
communication minister but resigned in
2012 after he accused the government of
sectarianism upon his appointment allowi
addressed iraqis in a late-night speech
pledging to address their demands whoa
now Shia I want to point towards the
necessity for the peaceful protest to
continue that support reforms until they
achieved their legitimate demands and
the government starts their genuine
reforms just like his predecessor allowi
promised to create jobs and fight
corruption and he vowed to bring those
responsible for the deaths of over 600
protesters to account I thought could
winner I confirmed that we're going to
investigate and bring those responsible
for the violence against peaceful
demonstrators to account the prime
minister-designate has 30 days to form a
cabinet which must be approved by a
parliament it has been deeply divided
over how to handle the latest crisis
some factions have rejected allow his
appointment but influential Shiite
cleric moqtada Sadr threw his weight
behind him
I don't think he has support from all
the political bloc's but there are
important political forces and I expect
that the service movement will stand
with him and if that's the case the
other political bloc's will do the same
for four months protesters have asked
for a complete overhaul of the political
system and an independent head of state
who isn't beholden to any domestic or
foreign powers allow his appointment
doesn't fulfill either of these demands
but it could end months of deadlock and
paved the way for early elections and
gradual reform semana 14 al Jazeera
Baghdad